well I'm gonna open the park park come
in come into my Park
or just wait for the bus like [ __ ]
on care not parks too good for you
hello welcome to an encounter the weekly
live streaming video game video game
video game playing show where we play a
different random you guessed it video
game on the Internet
today's random game 1994's theme park by
bullfrog productions this is a game I
originally played on the Amiga 600 and
we're about to play the PC version the
DOS version if you will which was the
one that I used to see in magazines and
be like holy [ __ ] look at the different
colored person which shirts they have in
this one and look they don't just have a
dancing chicken man they've a dancing
hippo man Wow alright a theme park in
our space age 69
who the hell filled us in HDMI hmd Ville
really Eric Tay
really I'm Stan I'm keeping hmd Ville so
let's go for ice cream first yeah yeah
he's already telling me I should raise
the price of my ice creams this guy's a
real piece of [ __ ]
yay all the people are enjoying our
theme park which only has a bouncy
castle in it and the kids are instantly
believing the [ __ ] theme park aquatic
oh and the Pentecost all right we need
more stuff any more stuff Oh God
weather effects were not ending Amiga
version
I would not like to be in the theme park
right now Jesus this is [ __ ] look
I've messed up this is there's so much
dirt everywhere gosh why is this game
going so fast never a go wow this is the
most traumatic theme park I've ever been
out in my life all right what else we
need all right we're starting to fill up
a bit these lines get nice and long
this thing's [ __ ] already all right we
need a mechanic Wow how am i last now I
was better before the park opens Jesus
your safety record is bad your
popularity of Park is poor is that black
all right the technology of your eyes is
bad it's not my fault that we need a
bike for them your ride compliment is
bad people think your park is average
all right team parks must be really
shitty if they think our one is average
after that review mechanic thick stuff
usually eating a sandwich
I just employed a man he eats a sandwich
you you fix that John this is the
filthiest Park in the world all right I
feel like we need more handyman this
place [ __ ] disgusting what's this guy
doing once employed 17 monthly wage zero
this guy's a [ __ ] idiot all right
stick around buddy stick around all
right your friend over here yeah you're
getting paid zero - yeah me too
okay let's see what our let's see what
our people think about our Park okay
this guy's happy this one dude is super
jazzed about this Park he probably has
really shitty life outside of the park
oh now he's pissed off it was to hurt me
damn it
and let's get a hippo dude hippo man
yeah he did the splits he's the best all
right is our Park still a piece of [ __ ]
what's going on
happy people we have people are actually
happy undecided people people are so
thirsty and hungry well the only thing
food I'm able to sell you people at the
moment is ice creams I'm not surprised
it's inner ice cream or coffee get out
some of my employees redundant so I need
to suck some of these jerks which one is
doing how are these guards being paid
nothing can I just get them to clean the
park as well
handyman working 100% Rhino man Rhino
man you gotta pull your weight man 300
quit being Rhino dudes or any more money
slowly but I still think I need to sack
the Rhino dude or have him killed I
don't know how I where is he
get off my Pentecostal you broke it you
idiots look at popular this week the
tree house it's got these people are
idiots
yeah oh it's because everything else is
breaking I have one grand left what the
hell happened I have to pay that Rhino
Matthew extra money I'm have to get in
there low and aren't I
that's solving the problem forever ray
yes I have just cheated
that work yes give me all the money give
me all the money shift see okay keep
keep keep a comment oh god I love the
flight sim pirate boat loop-de-loop
Space Shuttle dolphin act big wheel
medieval acts cowboy rocks these weren't
in the other one race car ride is this
what I think it is is this a track oh my
god alright I'm gonna build a new burger
hang out here I'm gonna make all these
people crash you can totally make it
have too many turns and go too fast or
two people crash and really hurt
themselves
it's great look at this super toilet it
costs four grand taking a [ __ ] is like a
religious experience in this toilet
that's what it's gonna get a bit funky
sure yeah why not now we're gonna
instantly have a really sharp turn so
it's gonna make sure that people fly off
this thing like loads of sharp turns
this one's got the shortest line in the
world have a go BAM
straight on yep first come first serve
with the Space Shuttle
you know space Shelton music and now
that's what some people died you know
that way No
perfect
yeah all right this is wait here see
what happens
not all right um great I don't think
there's enough speed there for that to
work I think people might actually die
now that's my name I'm not sure if
they've enough speed to make it but it
also looks like it oh [ __ ]
way to people threw off it already did
you see that these people just fling off
the pride all right let's take another
one of these things on this is really
[ __ ] with these people they're that
thing looks broken I don't know what's
going on there but whatever now it's
really a race to see who's the last
person that survives the
yeah keep going yeah oh yeah one person
made it the whole way around great my
safety records gotta be wonderful after
this oh this one's great I love this one
I used to love these ones and that it
was one of my hometown I was so bad and
it cost so much money I said love going
on it every time but now we have the
oculus rift you don't need this yeah
whoa what's going on here
stop negotiations I'll remember this if
to like I'll meet you halfway and meet
you there
now okay I'll just employ new people
then unemployed these dudes look just
like loads of them where's he going
are they picketing you picketing play
park you're gonna check it soon for
God's sake got that all right all right
it's fine fine yeah i garage seven point
for sure yeah keep going
no I'll sure I'm reaching the middle
I'll meet you in the middle don't be a
prick I'll meet you in the middle
don't be a prick all right it's being a
prey Wow this park is no staff all right
get on my rubber tubing green light it's
on great way look how much fun that is
all right all right okay
yeah look I'll meet you in the middle
I'll meet you in the middle I'll meet
you in the middle I'll meet you in the
middle
I want to see these people go flying
through my rubber tubing
how much fun is being had right now I'll
meet you in the middle right in the
middle in the middle I'm backing off I'm
backing off in the middle No all right
fair enough
come on okay all right okay all right
can I meet you in the middle yeah that
come over my side [ __ ]
no all right that's fine I can keep
building duck shoot things you're right
there and you can't eat any of my ice
cream come on Kevin yeah man yeah man
it's all about give and take
it's all about give and take yeah come
over here yay all right let's put some
super toilets around here BAM I remember
a nice play this as a kid I used to feel
real good when i unlock the super
toilets I felt like I was the pinnacle
of of owning a theme park was having the
super expensive
[ __ ] obviously having amazing
waterfalls fountains everywhere thank
you very much for joining me I don't yet
another sort of nostalgic random
encounter it's a video game history
month actually I'm in May on GameSpot
calm so we're gonna have a bunch of
features on this show on multiple
players obviously mega-bitch already had
talks a lot about classic games and the
lobby as well we're gonna have a bunch
of people on next month's to come on and
play their favorite classic video games
from their childhood including Greg
Kasavin Jon Carson twitch I'm at Greg
Miller for my jam as well and a bunch of
other folks so yeah stick around in case
what calm thanks very much for watching
tonight thanks Billy do Tom and Eric as
ever for working the back and I'll see
you guys next week if you have any
suggestions at Daniel Dwyer on Twitter
and have a great week bye